you
good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday we are on the other side of the
week
congratulations you made a [ __ ] the
other sad the other sad
the other side of the week i was doing
the other side of the door by taylor
swift
but i actually like yours better both
iconic both
so exciting in order to celebrate being
on the other side of the week
it's just the best feeling like and it's
crazy how this feeling comes
every week you know for yeah it still
feels so rare 52 weeks a year
28 years of my life and still the
feeling never gets old
never you know so congratulations
congratulations to everyone we made it
over the hump and we're sliding into
friday
sly just gonna slide right in like a rod
in san tropez
going to slide right in like derrick
path in my dms
we have a great show for you guys today
um i'm battling a little bit of a cough
so if i sound sexy and raspy try not to
get too turned on okay
yeah it's a little bit of perfect sticky
shoe syndrome
it's actually exactly that mustache
sticky shoes wow so i think you have to
sing more today
the other side of the door no i'm
honestly like not
having that type of cough like where my
voice sounds really good no i think it
does sound good but it's like
your voice sounds good but you know you
don't have the strength to sing like
you know it's like you don't have the
the joie de vivre no i don't have the
joada singh like you don't have a song
in your heart
and i always do i know and that's what's
really sad about being sick
i've been broken she's been broken this
is like she
persevered and she came today because
she said i must deliver the fast five
i have to do it and i am not covered
positive i did get a copy test so
there are other illnesses out there and
i think i've just got
a cough i think that and like the common
cold you know yeah even though
feels very uncommon well it always feels
uncommon and the cold is actually the
worst thing to have because nobody takes
you seriously
they're like you're such a [ __ ] cold
there's no medicine
that treats it you know you can have
soup and crackers no totally
maybe nobody respects you nobody
respects you but you're suffering
you know and it's like they just write
you off like oh it's just a cold but
it's like
it is because i feel like i'm on death's
door over here and it's not like when
you have ship you've got an antibiotic
and every day you're feeling better it's
like with the cold you just have to ride
it out
with no respect no there's nothing you
can do to shorten it like it's
i'm coming to terms with the fact like i
have a lot of weekend plans
that i might might not be able to go to
oh my goodness yeah but like i will not
give in to this illness like right after
the toast like i'm getting soup i'm
gonna take a
really really hot shower like break down
this mucus in my chest like i'm not
giving in
and i'm not giving up okay i just want
to let you know i'm so here for you
there's nothing i could do no i'm here
for your resilience but it's that sort
of attitude that sometimes
makes it worse and then totally then you
got a real problem
totally but if you just nip it in the
bud and listen to your body
oh i am i know but like you got to give
it a few days in bed and then like if
you were to do that by monday you would
be feeling better as opposed to
monday as opposed to monday pneumonia no
the thing is is that like being sick
as an adult is the [ __ ] worst because
i wish i was feeling this way on monday
then i knew like by the weekend i would
be feeling totally fine
but now it's like i don't even mind okay
whatever missing work sure whatever but
like when my
personal time off is
up for grabs yeah that's upsetting yeah
that is upsetting
and that's what i'm currently struggling
with yeah so i work too damn hard
for this pto to go home now i agree but
take it easy today
tomorrow we'll see where you at i'll
give you i'll give you an evaluation
tomorrow
yeah i did myself no favors yesterday
was a really busy day for me
but it was totally worth it even though
like i was dying on the internet
and now you can tell us all about your
secret project yes that wasn't your
secret to share
it was not even though i told taylor i
was like i almost spilled it on the toe
she was like
she's so chill she's like i literally
don't care it's hard to know i know when
i took all these pictures i'm like you
post first and then tell me what i can
post she was like no just post whatever
you want i'm like seriously
are you sure it's so it was so weird
like she's
she's really not like other girls truly
um so i went over to her house yesterday
i also podcasted like of course she gets
me for five minutes i'm the same with
her i'm like
need you on the podcast so we podcasted
for taste of taylor um
but then yesterday their wedding's in
like a couple weeks
taylor and taylor went to city hall to
get their marriage license they needed a
witness
and even though it really was like a
true formality like you had an
appointment at city hall
we had to make it special you know of
course they both were white as they were
getting dressed i ran across the street
to the dollar store
and got like the only things i could
find which was like
fake flowers and they didn't have any
nails so i just bought like confetti
poppers
and i was popping the confetti in city
hall and i did get in trouble because in
this climate you really can't do that
i didn't realize how loud they were yeah
and like to be making a mess
in city hall i cleaned it up i picked up
the confetti oh that's good i just
startled the employees with the popcorn
that's
really bad that's really bad and like i
think i embarrassed taylor and taylor
you know
yeah it was bad i didn't know this was a
sad story it goes downhill pretty quick
okay but but it seemed like
you know everything went well yes you
witnessed they licensed
i signed it and my name is like on all
their paperwork so
that's special that just felt special
well it's so nice that you did that and
that you just had such a fun
it was really fun day yesterday go
into the chat
[Music]
go into the chapel
[Music]
by the way this is like the song that
never ends this is really good these
were like true wedding bells
i can't believe that we like haven't had
an instrument to date like it took us
four years
four years that's horrible we need more
we need a ukulele
we do need a um shaker
shake shake shake tamarind tambourine
tamarind with a drug it has a drum and a
shake it's a twofer
yeah yeah for sure for sure yeah go
into the chapel wait
oh that was awkward yeah [ __ ] okay
go into the chapel and we're
gone again
literally ever no but like i just can't
relate to people who do like
everyone has to go and do the courthouse
wedding thing yeah
yeah and i can't relate to people who
like don't make it fun and corny
i we literally spoke about that on the
podcast that i did with taylor yesterday
because like it's a thing
it's a thing like i got all dressed up
and they do sell flowers right outside
no we went to jersey city because that's
where they currently reside and i
thought that they would you know in
manhattan they have like people you
could like pay one thousand dollars
to like be your witness take pictures
they they carry like
fancy cameras they didn't have that oh
okay well i'm glad you were still able
to make it your own obviously even just
wearing white like you must wear white
of course
can i tell you something i'm really
struggling with right now i see what
you're holding in your hand do you know
what i'm about to say
is about to be disrupted okay and i was
worried about you yesterday and i wanted
to help you
but i didn't want to step on your toes i
know i wish you had texted me to remind
me here
you were sick i didn't want to give you
jobs and you'd be like [ __ ] you do it
here's what happened no
i don't want you to do it like i'm
really i know i know i didn't want to
step on your toes but i would have
posted crochet
[ __ ] okay so when jackie left for her
trip
i got into a really good groove with our
instagram at the morning toast
the feed the feed and what i've started
to do is
we post a picture every day of us in
studio and then we update you guys on
the news
so i've decided to be really strict and
only post twice
after our initial in studio photo
because then we get a really cool flow
so if you'll switch to my individual
camera you'll see all of the pictures of
us in studio get lined up and it becomes
just like a cool thing
yesterday i was ill and busy and i only
posted once
so i think i should post right now okay
just to get it up and i'm just going to
post this picture of rochelle
okay and just say you'll
understand when you watch today's show
okay hold on but can you wait to post
that until like we finish recording that
way people can go and watch today's show
but then we're gonna post twice in a row
stranger things have happened
okay but like do not post that in studio
jack i always post it in studio photo i
won't
oh my god okay i won't until you give me
the green light because i know you have
you this passion of yours no and it's
like
it's only been going on for like a week
so like i want to make it so that like
forever you know no i know and it's like
if you if
if that one week you can't hack it like
it doesn't bode well so i think it's
not if i [ __ ] it up once i [ __ ] it up
forever i think it's important to take
these emergency measures okay so i'll
post it at the end of the episode before
our in studio photo yes and of course we
will be talking about chris because i
have so many thoughts and more than my
own thoughts i'm so curious to hear
yours
okay you know of course so do you think
without further ado did you do
for sure like we only have so long till
my voice gives out that's true and also
we'll give you your olympics mini recap
at the end of the show we are not going
to be spoiling what happened this
morning in tokyo
because if any of you don't know what
happened like you deserve to watch it in
prime time yeah and
you should all have the experience that
olivia austria robbed me of this morning
right and that's the second thing olivia
has wrapped me up she also robbed me of
the ending of the irishman
well not really yes i stand by that
olivia spoiled the irishman for me
just because i didn't know jimmy hoffa
was murdered oh sorry
just because i didn't know in real life
who the [ __ ] is jimmy hoffa like i
didn't know that he was murdered in real
life apparently olivia is like everyone
knew that everyone did not know that
so she really didn't have to support you
didn't know she didn't have to spoil
that's just like an obscure historical
fact
that's not like obvious like the titanic
it sunk like right that's
spoiler alert that's not a spoiler yeah
i agree also
um but like with the simone bile stuff
when it happened that morning we talked
about too big
it was everywhere like that just you
know there's a difference but you know
we'll save
that also um i've been watching white
light white lotus
um and i'll talk about it because i
don't think you need to watch it and
that's my okay that's my thesis
i mean like i literally cannot take
anything else on i had to break i
watched the olympics during the day too
and i had to take a break to watch
tuesday night's love island and honestly
it was the most anxious i've ever felt
in my life i'm like i've got to get back
to the olympics
that's not good it's not good no wonder
you're not feeling well the olympics are
like low-key ruining my life
like i'm enjoying it but it's so much
[ __ ] pressure and like you feel
pressure
i feel pressure yeah they feel totally
but like everyone's kind of like you
know like coming to me as like this like
olympics like kind of
connoisseur expert and it's it's
humbling for sure but it's overwhelming
yeah well no wonder you're not feeling
well you're too much on your plate too
much
okay without further ado it is time for
the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
noom when it comes to losing weight
there's a lot of pressure out there to
label foods as good or bad but that just
creates unnecessary dilemmas
noon is here to change how we see food
with a psychology-based approach
that looks at what you eat but also how
you eat instead of making you feel guilt
or regret
noon will empower you just to keep going
because you don't need rules to lose
weight you just need the knowledge and
wisdom to help you build smarter
more sustainable habits their cognitive
behavioral approach helps you unlearn
bad habits
and better understand your relationship
with food one size does not fits all
you can choose your goals and normal
personalized personalize your weight
loss program for you
eighty percent of numerous finish the
program and over 60 have stuck with the
goals for at least
a year because not everyone wants to be
on a strict diet do two a days at the
gym or drink
questionable teas now jackie i know
you've had a lot of um success with noom
can you tell me about that yes
i love noon because it's consistent it
holds you accountable
you know it's not high and low and also
it leaves room for error
it happens to all of us you're so human
but it's so nice to have
something to lean back on something to
lean on for more tools you know
i love their um calorie tracker they
have the biggest database of food so you
don't have to like go searching
endlessly to
or like input on your own what you're
eating and you can probably find it very
easily with nume
and it makes just keeping track of your
eating habits very easy and then you can
see you can see where you're at
yeah start building better habits for
healthier long-term results
sign up for your trial at noom.com toast
that's n o o m
dot com slash toast thank you toast
what do you got to lose thank you so
much you're so welcome
first story i would say this is the
biggest news of the day which says a lot
christelle stouse confirms she's dating
boss jason oppenheim selling sunset star
krashel
confirms she's dating the themed real
estate broker jason oppenheim who also
happens to be her boss
staus revealed the relationship with pda
packed photos hidden at the end of a new
instagram photo dump from a vacation to
capri italy
in one of the photos posted wednesday
oppenheim can be seen
kissing stouse's neck oppenheim
responded to the photos with a heart
emoji in the comments section
and then his brother commented love you
krishell thank you for making my brother
happy
then model tina who was also on the trip
i have to imagine she was there with
brett because then roman and mary were
there too
yeah so the model wrote oh
congratulations you guys finally ig
official you know letting people know
that she knew for a while i hate people
like that like so glad you could finally
share our secret oh my god it's been
i've been dying to like
share this so excited about this been
like bursting out of me like shut up
like we get a universe that doesn't make
you cool
no totally and but it also means that
they have been dating for more than just
a day
well can we talk about the atrocity that
was this quote-unquote
announcement okay if it weren't for the
comments i would have never known that
this was a relationship announcement it
was like group pictures it was a dump
then there's one photo where like yeah
that's an inappropriate place for like
his boss to put his lips like
that's the only thing that i was like oh
that's weird but i'm like they're so
close at the selling sunset offices like
it didn't strike me as anything and then
her caption was like the jlo effect
which i
today i was today years old when i
realized that meant putting your
relationship announcement
at the end of the photo dump okay
because to me the jlo effect
is i don't know being snatched at age 50
or like getting back
with your ex-boyfriend to me the jlo
effect was just being on a boat
in the mediterranean oh yeah yeah yeah
okay but
okay like literally i didn't read
anything into it so many people tagged
me and i'm like you guys i'd like
selling sunset but like i'm not this big
of a fan right
and then i think it was it eventually
dawned on me that they're dating and
it's just
like really shocking no it's shocking
for sure just because like
in my opinion he's just not that cute
but he's super rich so mary just must be
vomiting over this
um and she like had to caption like i'm
okay with it but like i just know she's
not
yeah like she used to do like um roman
commented so happy for you guys finally
people will stop with jason and mary
hopefully
wait take a step back
roma same as roman is it
are you sure rome okay roma then i'll
tell you where i got roman from
from joanna krupo when she was on rail
houses miami and her
man's name was roman okay okay i didn't
just make it up
no i think it is roman his name is wrong
his name is roman do you even watch
selling sunset it's
i i joined a group of lives in my mind
run free like i'm sorry
100 and so does vermont no that's toxic
[ __ ] relationship you know what i was
gonna make fun of you but like that is
such a reasonable explanation
i totally understand and i only have
space for one roman and it's joe and a
group of sex but are you 100 sure joanna
cooper's ex's name wasn't roman no i
feel really sure because i wouldn't just
like start calling people where i'm
on i mean you've called people the most
random things
um but back to what you had just said
his caption
his comment his comment can you read it
again so happy for you guys finally
people will stop with jason and mary
hopefully
you know because everyone on the show of
course i know what that means okay but i
just want to talk about like the level
of loser dumb
in just like actually saying that out
loud yeah i agree
i think it's like a 10 out of 10. i
agree especially because
i saw that comment but i didn't i hadn't
seen who wrote it yet i thought it was
like just another maybe like you know
um the girl taurek's heather ray young
heather ray young that's something like
heather ray young could say and i'd be
like oh okay it's like
a joke from the show yeah for mary's
husband to say that
i don't know no but i actually just like
feel really sad for mary
i hated mary like the whole time
because she's like trying to make this
relationship with roman like
happen and it's like it's not going to
happen it's like happening
it is happening but like
she went from dating jason who's like
the boss everyone like loves him he's
super wealthy they're so successful
and like then she's like bankrolling
this like kid
as her husband like it's just not an
ideal situation so i'm sure what she's
feeling is like you know
seeing rachelle live out her dream oh
you think so
but i feel like at any point she could
have said goodbye to ramon
no i don't think she could have you
don't no
i think like jason was like done with
her like the second
it started like that's just what i think
okay interesting
he expressed not one more soul of
interest in her romantically
barely even as a friend like in the
entire time i watch that show you know
who i really need to know
how christine i need to know how
christine feels about this like this
trip
this everything i'm sure she could not
give a [ __ ] i feel like she is so
um just like on the outside like she's
still part of the show and she's gonna
be amazing and i can't wait to watch but
like
you know she's also in like um in the
amalfi coast and
they're not meeting up yeah of course
because she can afford her own trip like
she doesn't need to get on her boss's
boat
but also when it comes to christine like
there is a weird level of like
intimacy with this group of people like
technically what we're supposed to
believe is like they all work together
would you ever go on vacation with your
co-worker no like most normal people
wouldn't
so like and like would you have dinner
with your coworker every night and then
go out to dinner with your co-workers
and then wake up and have breakfast with
your co-workers before you go back to
work
no it's just like an unhealthy maybe
like sorry christine has a normal
work-life balance
no i completely agree i just sound like
a man like
oh with you no it doesn't sound that bad
okay actually but i don't know
and i'm sorry i just coughed directly
into the mic like that was so rude a
little treat for you guys
um but let's talk about the relationship
itself right
like like i'm not living for this in any
in any way and it's just it's really
surprising
i just feel like rochelle is one of
those girls who literally has the worst
taste in men because
i despise justin hartley even when you
look at these pictures and the body
language like it's
not there no no it's that's such such an
excellent point
as a body language expert myself there
is so much space
between them but they're also like close
so they're like
it's fake like for sure i don't think
it's fake but i just don't think she's
that into it like i think
i don't know what happened that like led
her in this direction but i just don't
think that this is like the greatest
love story of our time
and i disagree with you about justin
hartley oh my god if justin hardly
literally busted into the studio i was
like claudia marry me right now i'll
give you anything you want i'll make you
the star of this is us
i would literally tell him to get out
like i despise him well i wouldn't want
to be the star of this is us either but
you know but he's so handsome no he's
home and successful
despise okay well
like yes traditionally his looks like
from a completely non-biased third-party
perspective could make up a handsome man
but the man inside no that i could get
behind that
i don't know the man inside but we only
like it's like justin timberlake we saw
no
no because his looks are not it yes they
are arbitrarily if we came from another
planet and we saw him be like oh yeah
okay i guess this is a handsome man no
but
from the second a word came out of his
mouth
and he danced and had his curly ramen
noodle hair
it was a no for me no i disagree
i don't think you could say that justin
timberlake is not
like handsome in a completely
let me look i haven't looked at him in a
while yeah i guess i haven't either
let me look show me pics i'm going
it's gonna be may it's tough it's
really tough actually
i don't know i actually think he looks
better in these pictures than i was
thinking
really i think he looks worse wait show
me again like he looks like robbie hayes
that was a really nice compliment to
robbie hayes
he looks like richard madden a little
bit you know what
justin timberlake is not cute i mean
i've been trying to tell you
i just thought like because he's so
mediocre and he got so famous like he
must be handsome
so i'd never even questioned it but now
that i just looked at this photo
that's not a cute man and this was like
number two photo on google images like i
wasn't trying he said the oscars i
wasn't trying to sabotage
no i actually chose a photo where i
think he looks really nice better than i
remember do you think jason
oppenheim is cute he's not my type
yeah for sure but he's a cutie and he
has a really nice personality on the
show and he's like a nice boss
you hit him with a personality no like
any
like he's he's cutie like i'm not i'm
not saying
anything i'm not saying about anything
about that either of them
as individuals i'm just saying these two
together like
what what went wrong honestly yeah
and even these pictures like still if it
wasn't for everyone saying that it's
because they're in a relationship like
this is how you pose with your boss who
you really like and you go on trips and
yacht trips with
yeah not the kicking of the neck but for
that yeah that's not a couple
this was the worst announcement ever
like how are we supposed to this is not
a couple
everyone on the youtube okay
no yeah no
so that's my thoughts on that i mean
clearly they are dating and they're
saying they're a couple for sure but
like talk about the worst announcement
ever like having absolutely no grip on
like social media
behaviors and i just like i just don't
think this is
a great love story no this isn't it for
christelle no
i i agree but i look forward to watching
this season and see the circumstances
that brought them to this conclusion
right like how desperate did she have to
like what circumstances left her feeling
that desperate
yeah yeah yeah maybe justin hartley like
showed up and like ripped her new one
and she was just looking for a friend
i know i guess for a friend and also
it's like jason he's always like with
models right and like
what made him like after knowing her
shell for three years now like
be like krichelle's the one yeah that's
a good question you know for both of
them so it's not like
either one of them is not worthy of the
other like i actually think they're both
individually
interesting people mm-hmm i just want to
put them together what changed yeah
and also like whose idea was it to have
this terrible caption and photo series
yeah yeah that's what i really want to
know i agree
so we'll keep you posted um on the most
random couple news
that i've heard yeah but like it's not
that random like because they're on the
same show but i literally would have
never even
thought twice about i'm like no no they
could literally be
making out in these pictures and i would
be like why are you guys tagging for the
show
why am i being tagged totally are you
ready for our next story which is some
exciting content news
some exciting content news finally you
see nf ec
news finally ucf
ecnf hbo max's satirical series about
the royal family the prince
will air start streaming today
we got a trailer we got a trailer that
was so hysterical
like and it really so i didn't know what
to expect i thought it was gonna be
mostly george but it's ev everyone's
there
queen megan harry will kate everyone yes
so i'm really looking forward to see how
gary interpreted everyone's personality
um but hbo max's anticipated satirical
animated comedy about the royal family
the prince
has finally set a release date and it's
much sooner than you think the streaming
service will drop the first 12 episodes
of the gary janetti created cartoon
at 3 a.m on thursday so it is live now
the prince
is a heroic twist about the imagined
inner mechanics of the firm through the
lenses
of an animated prince george who is the
eldest son of william and kate
the youngster is third in line of
succession to the british crown
i feel like a lot of people don't know
because they know gary from instagram as
like
funny instagram guy husband cute part of
a
dynamic power couple with brad but he's
like one of the most successful writers
he's written like for family guy right
forever yes so he got his own show like
writing-wise and he does the voice right
he does the voice of prince george of
prince george so like i feel like this
is like going to be shocking for people
because they only know him for like
young people
know him from instagram yeah but he has
all the chops to make this a very great
and he was like way successful before
his instagram blew up
yes also here is the cast it's some
really inspired casting
orlando bloom is playing prince harry
orlando bloom is playing prince harry
okay
you know this is a palace inside of a
larger palace
alan [ __ ] is playing george's butler
owen oh fabulous
i saw alan coming on the street once
riding a bike and like singing and i was
like
that track i was waiting for the light
and he like biked right past me and i'm
like i think that was alan coming and he
turns around and he was like it was
france is still a tourist queen
elizabeth miller lucy punch is kate
middleton
don't know her condola rashad is meghan
markle i'm from earlier
ewyn rhian is prince william where's
sophie turner
sophie turner is princess charlotte i
feel like she doesn't have a big role
dan stevens is prince charles he is from
downton abbey and he's also voices the
beast in beauty and the beast
stop oh my god and he will be playing um
charles sorry stevens is also voicing
prince philip
wow he's a twofer he's got a lot of good
voice work going yeah
i mean that's probably why he was cast
from beauty and the beast it was a lot
of voice work
oh my god that's so exciting i'm
actually gonna watch it today even
though like
i probably have to wait until after the
olympics like i can't spare a minute
of my free time watching anything about
the olympics but i really want to watch
this
because you know the trailer gave me
major vibes three
two one alan gregory yes um which was
the most underrated animated show of all
time
voiced by jonah hill the main character
and i just feel like not enough people
talk about it i mean some of these
animations are like really savage to be
honest yes
like look at prince philip oh that's and
look at william like i think that's
probably
considering william's still alive that's
probably like the worst one
yeah um queenie looks like queenie queen
looks like queen
and charles looks like charles looks
like charles megan and harry
look i i feel like i wonder how much
they're going to be in it but they
looked
like fine fine they looked like cartoons
so i would say william was
like the most slighted most delighted
for
sure because prince george looks
adorable adorable he looks like alan
gregory
yeah no he's so [ __ ] cute justice for
alan gregory
i wonder if jonah hill knows like the
impact of that one show that he probably
did one days of
one day work for i feel like if he had
chosen ruthie
he would know yeah he obviously like has
bad
choices decision making skills cause he
didn't choose ruthie and he didn't
choose alan
i agree disgusting disgusting are you
ready for our next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you by vivino
we all enjoy a nice glass of wine
especially after a long day
during a fancy dinner and we're no
experts but we know what we like and we
also love trying new varieties
like wines our local stores don't carry
so that's why we use vavino the world's
biggest online wine marketplace
they're also the largest online wine
community with 50 million users who have
related
who have rated and reviewed just about
every wine
they carry a lot of our favorites plus
they they suggest
exciting personalized recommendations
for you based on your taste
if you never knew that certain ones
existed you'll know even more now about
what you do
like thanks to vivino i have the same
experience i drink the same like one
wine and i'm really not like
experimental you know i don't like to
try new things
but vavino just like i told them what i
liked they sent me what i liked and they
also sent me some things they thought i
would like
and they have a really good system for
that because i actually really ended up
enjoying a lot of the wines that i got
and they have an app and it's everything
that you need to know about wine
it's right in the palm of your hand you
can see all the ratings reviews you can
also leave your own and of course you
can buy wine our favorite thing to do is
to scan a bottle when we're shopping
in store and see what vavino's users say
about it so if you're in store you can
still use the app you can buy
buy wine on the app you could also use
it if you're buying elsewhere to get
some details on this bottle of wine
we've really stepped up our wine game
thanks to the vino give them a try and
we know you're going to love it
go to vavino.com toast and use the code
toast at checkout
to save 20 off your first order of up to
200.
that's v-i-v-i-n-o dot com
toast code toast to save 20 off your
first order
of up to 200. the vino.com toast
code toast seaside for details terms
apply thank you so much for that you're
welcome
next story rihanna is picking sides in
rahone feud between
liam mcsweeney and ramona singer the bad
gal is known as a bravo fanatic who
follows her favorite stars on social
media and occasionally weighs in on
various real housewives happenings
and sometimes she even gets name dropped
in an episode so
this week the fight broke out between
ramona and leah um
ramona quipped that she would promote
leah's brand mistaken call
mistakenly called married to the mob
leah mob or mob something
and leah replied you're not exactly my
demographic so it's all good
i already have rihanna wearing my [ __ ] i
don't need you wearing my [ __ ]
so rihanna posted a carousel photo the
first one in
a t-shirt that says [ __ ] mob obviously
from primary to the mob and then a slide
of
her tv filmed of this scene and then she
said what was said at ramona singer
crying laughing emoji oh my god you guys
like this
every now and then rihanna pops her head
up to let us know she's still watching
bravo
and i do believe the last time she
acknowledged the bravo universe
was um with tom schwartz like a million
years ago he was brushing his teeth and
was just like a random funny scene and
she was like cracking up
yeah so we haven't heard from her and
i'm like glad to know she's still
keeping up even with the worst of the
shows
real housewives of new york she
obviously has a lot of free time since
she's not releasing an album so
i'm really glad that she's still on the
train with us right but i do think she's
also the last remaining person on the
leah
yes what i was gonna say on the leah
train i couldn't really understand like
what the meaning of her message was
and i'm afraid that it means she's on
team leah
she definitely is like she put the shirt
on she took a picture yeah
and she inserted herself but also like
if the show you're watching says your
name like you're gonna of course
you're gonna jump in i'm actually so
curious as to how many
t-shirts leah sold
from that post like i wonder if that was
good for business i always forget leah
has a business
yeah i mean i can't imagine it was bad
for business but i also just sometimes
feel like
those things don't really happen anymore
like you know yeah like you know it used
to be back in the day so and so was
photographed and it's like sold out yeah
and that still happens i feel like with
kate middleton and meghan markle but
like
now it's there's so much like content
there's so many celebrities there's so
many influential people
and a lot of times people are like
skeptical of what people are wearing
thinking that it's like sponsored
yeah i just feel like i mean you never
know
maybe one day like leah will share i'm
sure andy will ask her that at the end
yeah now we have something to talk about
yeah totally um finally so
yeah rihanna's still watching bravo
she's team leah and leah now is probably
going to be like
even more empowered to be annoying yeah
exactly
totally but i'm so glad rihanna's still
with us
like i thought we might have lost her
because so much of the content went so
downhill
but rihanna she's just like us she has
plenty of free time
are you ready for our next story yeah
just
wrong wrong mm-hmm
w what is it kelly clarkson will have to
pay brandon blackstock 200
000 in monthly support kelly clarkson
has been ordered to pay her estranged
husband brandon blackstock nearly 200
thousand dollars in monthly spousal and
child support
starting on april 1st the singer will
have to pay black stock 150k per month
in spousal support
an hundred additional 45 dollars per
child and cha
per month in child support for the
benefits of their two children
seven-year-old river rose
and five-year-old remington according to
legal documents obtained by the blast
she'll also have to pay all of black
stocks legal fees which amount to 1.25
million dollars
they're kidding that this interesting
factoid alert the documents
also state the daytime talk show her
host earns more than 1.5
per 1.5 million dollars per month in
income okay so she's earning 1.5 million
dollars in income per month she has to
put away half for taxes
she's at seven fifteen she's at ten
percent for agent ten percent for
managing well no they wouldn't consider
it her income at one point five
that would be post commission post
commission post post tax
no no no not post tax because kelly
clarkson herself is only receiving the
1.5 because your agency gets the money
they take their percentage and then they
give it to you so
1.5 750 minus taxes so she's literally
giving away
30 percent of her monthly income to this
debt
no that's me i'm not gonna say cause i'm
sure he's a wonderful father but like
this just really bothers me
yeah i think about there's a lot of
people and you know what
it's so funny about this like i'm all
for gender equality like i truly am but
some things just rub me the wrong way
and this like a man taking 200
000 a month from a woman a mother from
the hardest working woman in hollywood
who deserves like who's finally getting
like what she deserves like
the voice the kelly clarkson show the
tour like she's finally getting her
place in hollywood and she's having to
give up so much of that
for her [ __ ] loser ass ex-husband is
this the one who's related to reba
yeah reba shames you brandon
shames yeah this is disgusting but like
i just can't stress enough like if the
rules were reversed i'd be like yes
kelly get that
money what's the news yeah there's just
something
and i can't stress enough like how i'm
all for equality but like some things
just some things just aren't right
i agree things just are and you know
what like when we're reporting on
opposite roles it's because when you're
divorced like more often than not
of course everything every case is
different but like majority of the
custody goes to the mom so the mom
deserves
child support yeah also kelly is the mom
she alleged that he acted fraudulently
as her manager
so like that's [ __ ] chessy and also
he has given up his career as manager
and is pursuing a full-time career as a
rancher on his montana ranch his future
career plans will include sponsoring
rodeos and working the ranch well i
would also quit my job as a manager if i
knew i was getting two hundred and fifty
i would go live the ranch life on the
farm 200 plus then 40 right
for child support no no it 200 because
it's 150 plus 40 okay so 200 times 12 is
what
24 no i'm sorry yeah
so he's making 2.4 million dollars in
salary for literally sitting on his ass
yeah on his ranch i would quit and
become a rancher too
yeah oh this makes me stronger she has
to pay his legal pills
chest is for [ __ ] kelly we have
to get her like a new job like
like she did she wants to raise yeah
what's next because now she has to
support
this schmuck
yeah also did you see the new trailer
for the voice yeah of course was so good
it was so good what song did she sing um
from greece hopelessly devoted but now
there's nowhere to hide since you
push my love aside i'm out of my head
hopelessly devoted to
you hopelessly
devoted to you
so yeah we just had ariana grande on the
show um so thank you for being here ari
i loved the trailer i loved the trailer
it was so cute like such a cute concept
i feel like they're all like really nice
like i know what celebrities are
like whatever i just happen to feel like
the four people who are hired as voice
coaches right now
are really four of the nicest
celebrities there's no doubt in my mind
that kelly
kelly is nice there's no doubt in my
mind that blake sheldon is nice there's
a small down in my mind that john legend
only because he's married to christy
tegan and she's like
a professional like mean person but i do
feel like he's really nice and ari is
definitely like cool as hell
i just i don't i think on these ensemble
shows where it's not just about one big
star there's no room for these stars to
take up
all the air and the energy no and
there's no room for people to be hired
who are those types of celebrities
and it won't work out so i think they
have to and that just goes to show like
blake shelton must be the nicest man in
hollywood because he's been on every
season
and i feel like he's probably like the
alpha
of the show in terms of like you know
everyone goes to him and he probably
like is just like the father figure i
think he's had the most success
with like talent no but like it i'm sure
out of all the judges
it feels more like blake's show because
he's been there the longest he doesn't
act like it and he makes that show
clearly a welcome environment totally
so that's on blake and i just loved that
little campfire a little setup it was
i loved the whole thing like it was
really really sweet and i'm not someone
who like goes
googly eyes for a trailer no me neither
but also just back to what we were
saying
we need to brainstorm some projects
kelly can pick up just to make up for
that 250k
per month like she's got to start doing
some sponsored posts on her instagram i
agree because i don't know how much
actual like
time she's time yeah you know but like
we gotta get her like a crest
sponsorship or something you know one
post a month or like a commercial
endorsement
yeah yeah like she should be the
the voice of like halls what are they
called
lozenges like because she needs to
protect her voice she's like one of the
best voices of our generation
yeah well speaking of one of the best
voices of our generation truly
adele is reportedly considering las
vegas residency with a huge payday
i feel like we've spoken about this i
know we're always talking about
potential residencies which isn't like
my favorite type of news but
no but i think before covert a lot of
the news we were talking about like was
gonna come true right and then
everything was halted but adele is
considering performing a residency in
las vegas where she could earn a
staggering
138k per night according to a new report
that's what kelly needs see
oh my god she wants to go to her
residency no she has that coming up
still oh good okay because like
she needs she needs to do two shows a
month
and then she'll make up for her husband
who she's like
literally carrying through this world
yeah soon city sources tell the sun that
the rolling in the deep singer is
mulling a residency at the strip's new
venue
resorts world which claudia actually
went to the opening yeah so maybe you
could tell us where you could envision
this taking a little bit you think i'm
like so
hazy where where was there even like a
could begin as early
as january of next year okay first of
all
great location like right by the wind
definitely good location for adele okay
really nice hotel too like
clean adele approved adele approved i
didn't see like the theater because i
went to the casino and i went to the
club
that sounds like you for sure but um i'm
sure they have like a sickening thing
they have a theater which holds just
about 5 000 people and they're already
slated to host performances from katy
perry luke bryan celine dion carrie
underwood
ooh fabulous yes throw a dell in there
i do feel like i don't know why
something about adele just
i feel like she's not ready for that yet
only in the sense that like
i think a lot of the time people who do
residencies
aren't retired per se but they're headed
towards that part of their career
they still a lot of them still release
music but like they're not as heavily
anticipated as adele's next album i
agree with you completely
in the way that we used to look at
residencies but the residency formula
has changed it's not now someone who
like lives out their days in the las
vegas desert and
comes in every night to sing their songs
like oh
i haven't watched hacks yet you don't
have no but i'm going to it's like it's
top of the list actually i should
probably watch it today like oh my god i
really
like need you to watch okay i'm gonna
watch it today oh my god i can't believe
you haven't watched it that's like this
that's what it used to be you know like
wayne yes yeah like
celine that was it but not even sling
but then i remember before covey there
was all these stories like
cardi b is doing a right yes and it
turned into more like
just a five night stay in las vegas or a
few months two-week run
yeah or it's like you don't have to live
there in order to do it so i feel like
there's residencies in the way that we
classically know them like you are
living in las vegas
and you're working every day you're sort
of like
at that stage in your career and then
there's also like cash grab
residency vegas which is like when they
want to bruno mars it's not it has
nothing to do with with like
should be it has nothing to do with them
putting you on the shelf yeah yeah no i
agree
i agree cool i'm glad we're in agreement
but that then it feels like coven ruined
all that and like we're back to like
that old school
just add it to the list yeah it's
i mean it would be really far down but
totally it ruined yeah totally
yeah and also ruined our experience of
going to see kelly clarkson
premiere night las vegas residency we
had a table we literally bought the best
table
and i'm almost like 500 sure i never got
my money back it was just gonna be the
best night of my life
no i know and it was also the same
weekend as cma fest in vegas
it was so sick i had a dress and
everything i still have the delta credit
i know that but i'm like i remember
getting an email from ticketmaster
they're like
we're just not gonna refund everyone now
oh okay
sure yeah sure like we're coming and
that was like literally two years ago oh
my god well i guess that means we're
still going but you know what
kelly can keep the money because she
deserves it well now you know what's
going to brandon
oh no snatch it up
um so those were the fast five stories i
feel as though you needed to know them i
felt like they were very fast and very
five
we have a small tv recap because i want
to talk about some of the olympics that
i watched yesterday and i know you
what did you watch white lotus which
everyone is talking about so our mini tv
recap segment is brought to you by
legacy box a super simple mail and
service to have all your video
tapes camcorder tapes film wheels and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive
dvd or the cloud if your family's
memories
are trapped on an old camcorder a tape a
film reel
your childhood memories are just locked
up
introducing legacy box a way for you to
easily and affordably digitally preserve
your past
the process from start to finish is
super easy you pack and send the items
their team will digitize everything by
hand and then you enjoy you'll get back
perfectly preserved digital copies on a
thumb drive a dvd or the cloud
ready to watch share and enjoy
everything is digitized by hand
at their secure 8 acre digitizing campus
where they use premier scanners and
playback decks to ensure each memory is
mastered to the highest quality plus
they keep you up to date with regular
email updates throughout the process
of the digitization they are the world's
largest digitizer of home movies and
photos and they have helped over 850 000
families
digitally preserve their past get start
future get started for future proofing
your memories today so you can gather
the family
and begin a trip down memory lane go to
legacybox.com
toast to get an incredible 40 off your
first order if you buy today and take
advantage of this exclusive offer you
can send it in when you're ready but
make sure to go to legacybox.com
toast to save that 40 while supplies
last thank you so much for that claudia
legacy box it's the best idea that you
wish you thought of no like literally i
would not be sitting here if i thought
of legacy box because it's the best
[ __ ] idea
um okay the olympics i watched so i
watched like all day yesterday and then
obviously like the prime time was men's
gymnastics and swimming
now i you know what justice for men's
gymnastics because i was watching a
little bit a few days ago and like
it was so on point and they just don't
get you know the shine that they deserve
because those girls just
sparkle like the top of the chrysler
building totally and they do the same
level of tricks
some of them that pommel horse thing
that's
the male male beam oh my god yes
it's impossible so like you're right
america lost they didn't even place
whatever
really yeah but during the day i did
watch men's
synchronized um diving which is so
interesting like it's just the the
nbc had this woman
emceeing whatever it's called
correspondent and when i watched women's
diving synchronized yesterday by myself
she was the host and she was so negative
that's so funny did i say that already
you did and then i saw a comment that
people like she was negative she was
except my god she was on point like
literally i watched again yesterday with
the same woman and ben
mentioned her i'm like she's like so
negative but every time she says
something she's 100 on point
she said like these people can't get
higher than a 75. no she said they might
get a little higher than a 75 they got a
77.
she actually knew everything it's like
maybe she wasn't being negative maybe
everyone was just stinking it up
okay i have a question that i was
wondering when i was watching the
coverage of
simone biles exiting the all around
is the commentary live in real time yes
they okay so with simone biles that
should happen at 6 45 a.m
they aired it on primetime which is when
you watched it at 8 p.m but they air
it's still on nbc at 16 15 commentary
same commentary just nobody's watching
because who the [ __ ] is awakened because
i was like they could have like if they
knew what was coming
you know it might have informed what
they said it was all in real time and
they replay
the live great thank you for that that's
a good question i thought the same thing
okay so because then she imagine she
watches the squares and then she records
her audio
they can't get higher than 75 no time
and she has the answers to the test
totally no i do believe it's all in real
time
and so after day two of watching
synchronized diving
i had enormous respect for the woman and
i take back what i said
she was incredible and she was nailing
every single point like she was just
what a roller coaster
i'm telling you nobody on the planet
earth knows more about synchronized
diving than this woman like
she was so well read and like so smart
and she had this great like southern
accent which first i found annoying but
now that i'm in love
with her i think it was really good wow
i'm so happy we love you know a change
of heart
no totally and then i watched um
so america won silver
and they were really good i'm really
happy with that but like every time i'm
watching something like china is just
winning
everything like i i know you can like i
actually want to check this morning like
the official account yeah i want to
check you i check it like
every five minutes um olympic medal
count if you just google it you guys i
know a lot of people don't know this
just comes up oh that's cool and also if
you open peacock they have it there too
okay or you could google it okay so we
have the most overall
metals 38 next is china with 31 and then
japan with 25
but in terms of gold medals japan and
china have 15 and we have 14. right not
bad
not bad not bad i just like wish we were
more ahead
yeah wait so who's top three in the
medal overall
overall china japan us okay
oh no i'm sorry i'm sorry china us
republic russian olympic which like i
think we spoke about that yesterday but
roc russian olympic committee just feels
unfair like if you're disqualified
you're just qualified like
you don't get to like come back with a
news
um okay and then i watched of course
what everyone tuned in for yesterday
caleb dressel he had already won
one gold medal but that was like a relay
that he won with his four teammates and
they won so easily like they were
obviously gonna win
but then like i love a relay totally sad
i missed this yeah
but that was a couple days ago that was
a couple days ago then last night he ran
his first individual one and he won it
was the men's
free 200 and he won by like literally
one hundredths of a second
and he's just so [ __ ] hot like
there's just nothing
he's just so hot and then he went for
his
interview post race and he was just like
very overwhelmed
and before he brought they brought in
his family via microsoft teams but
before that it was a sponsorship
before that he was just like he was
crying he's like it's just been like
such a hard year and he was just like
really giving me like
some mobiles like on like really
struggling vibes and i'm like
this is what's the word i'm looking for
it's not just simone it's prevalent
amongst all athletes like
he was literally like just unwell then
they brought in his family
they were on microsoft teams in orlando
and he just like lost his mind he was
crying like
his wife was just like they couldn't
even hear each other they were just like
talking on top of each other and his
parents were there and then his brother
came in like
it was so beautiful and stunning i feel
like the impact of these athletes not
able
not to have their families they both
have a family not one person not even
like
usually your whole family would go
everyone who's on teams in orlando would
be there in the cheering section we'd be
seeing them
but to not even let them have one person
of support i think
contributes majorly to this
mental health crisis that we're seeing i
could not agree more and
very few of the athletes are incredibly
lucky that their
husbands wives or like parents are their
coach
and that's the only what reason that
they're able to be there with them but
that's because
they're their coach right but most
people's coaches are just coaches
they're not related to them right
so it's i agree it's a crisis and it's
like if everyone just had their mom or
their dad or their
partner it would make a world of
difference i really agree
i completely agree as well so that's
interesting um and then
because i'm sick i fell asleep like i
just needed to stay up for caleb dressel
and i went to bed at like 10 o'clock so
it's not my fault
um i don't know what ended up happening
i i know katie ledecky swam but i don't
know if she won so i'm sorry like i'm
letting
she won silver okay who won gold it was
a relay oh it wasn't her fault okay
who won gold do you know who won gold
irrelevant yeah not america
not australia oh okay yeah australia is
like killing it
china no china wins everything like
it's just not fair from what i think the
ones that i have caught
like the um it was china the sports that
i have caught it really feels like
everybody's winning you know a little
bit of this a little bit of that
really everything canada every sport i
watch it's like
china winning by mile and america in
like second or third
interesting okay maybe we're just
watching different things i agree
um because you're watching white lotus
so how was that because i was watching
white lotus which i saw people were
talking about and like it's about um the
premise is like
all these random people are on vacation
in hawaii
at this resort jennifer coolidge is on
jennifer coolidge is in it and like
she's so amazing but her character i
just like don't fully understand yeah i
mean she
does an amazing job but like you're just
constantly waiting for the other shoe to
drop with the show and the way that it's
filmed like the scenes are
really long and there's a lot of talking
but it's like usually in shows you only
say
like really every word that's spoken is
like intentional and you know you don't
just like waste time just talking about
this right but like
there's just the way that it's filmed i
guess it's like quirky and meant to be
like
interesting but it's just it's kind of
stupid honestly
and the show there's only three episodes
out so far which i didn't realize when i
started i hate that
like starting something with nothing to
give yeah and it's just like
i don't if everyone's talking about the
show like it's just because it's on hbo
max and it's pretty star-studded i mean
connie britton's in and she's amazing
she's probably my favorite character
but like her daughter the teenage girls
like they're just like such [ __ ] and
like
i just i'm like what am i watching like
what's the point totally what's the
point who else is in it
um the girl from the throuple in why
women kale oh you know what i do believe
i saw a clip of this on tick tock does
it turn out that connie
britton's husband's father
was gay yeah yeah i saw like a clip of
it on tick tock oh and it was like
supposed to be funny people were sharing
it and
i didn't get it oh interesting um yeah
that's like one storyline he's just like
having a
hard time uh yeah some sort of mid-life
crisis because he also got him went on
the trip and like his testicles were
swollen which they showed us
they showed us big balls
and like i'm surprised that didn't go
viral on tick-tock
white lotus episode one right 20.
like and it's just like the way that it
it was like we were watching a different
couple
scene right and then flash to the next
scene and we're just on testicles like
yeah it wasn't like they're talking
about and then they show us
yeah it just opened like it was really
crazy just
testies just testies for the resties and
so he like went on the trip thinking
that he might have testicular cancer and
then you know i won't spoil it
no i won't um so he's having this sort
of just like
crisis life like you know what is life
existential crisis existential crisis
like let's make the most of every day
but his son just like wants to play
video games
of course like [ __ ] off dad no but it's
also like you're at this amazing resort
in hawaii like i can't relate to being
on your
nintendo the whole time of course and
also just like watching these shows it's
like i don't know if all kids are like
the
kids in the show but it's like it's
really [ __ ] bleak i know
no kids these days are they're so mean
moody and like what all they do is drugs
like
i just i don't literally that's what it
sounds like i definitely remember being
like a mean moody teenager but i don't
think i was really doing drugs no and
like
you still have respect for like of
course no parents
and authority no not anymore stuff not
anymore
not anymore so i mean i'll keep watching
because it's pretty like aesthetically
pleasing
in terms of like it's set at a resort
and it wasn't like bothering
me but i'm just like again like what's
everyone watching
right right right like why all the
hoopla right but now we have the prince
now we have the prince obx season two
comes out tomorrow i heard yeah looks
high
i'm like i don't know if maybe because i
was just like so hyped up on it and it
was coved like
i don't even care like i feel like you
know i feel like season one was really
good but seriously
looks like too much chaos yeah and it's
like i can only suspend disbelief for so
long like these 16 year olds are
treasure hunting and they're running
away to the bahamas like i can't like
where are your parents no they're the
ones chasing them right like right
please
yeah no it's all a little crazy so i
need to watch hacks i need to
you need to catch up on love island i
need to uh it's a tall task
i know but tomorrow's friday so we
haven't done any recaps this week
because you're behind that wouldn't mean
i would have to watch
everything today yes you have to watch
all of love island today so we could do
a recap tomorrow
oh my god because we also have no tv
recap tomorrow
well what if i were to watch something
else interesting that people wanted to
hear about
no but the cook of castlemark but on
netflix but i didn't watch
it i didn't watch it yesterday but
yesterday was the recoupling ceremony
from casa moore so like there's a lot
happening oh and someone sent me a
picture
like is it a spoiler yeah i'm not going
to say i'm not going to say what it was
but they sent me
a spoiler picture because i guess like
someone in the house
sleeps with one eye open and like you
see it who she's with a couple
yeah that's really like someone who
wears don't tell me from my pov
it's like this person is very much in a
couple i thought you
don't don't don't don't judge me don't
don't don't seriously seriously
i think you were going to say someone
sent you a picture of someone sleeping
in tmt merch
that's a delusional i am that would be
amazing yeah i know have you checked all
their instagram see if there's any
toasters on the show yeah i think i
checked like the second the show started
and none of them were not even casamore
amora casamore no i haven't checked but
none of them gave me toaster energy the
only one who did was shannon
and she let me down no but it's always
it's never what you expect
no but also like seeing these people's
instagrams because they haven't been
able to update them so you're seeing
what they look like before they're
famous
jeremy's instagram you have to look at
it is the biggest piece of losery
content
it's just every single day a new mirror
picture of him without a shirt on it's
so illusory yeah that's really bad it's
really bad
that's really bad you should have just
like started a brand new instagram like
yeah it's like left in little mystery
totally
damn um okay so we will do our best to
recap love island we'll do our best but
some of us might watch hacks or the
hookup castle our new period piece
dropped on netflix thank god
it looks so good juicy you want to wrap
up my throat hurts
i would love to wrap up thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
do need to know
every monday through friday on podcasts
on youtube
audio video it's just so fabulous there
are so many different platforms where
you can consume our content
the podcast app spotify stitcher public
radio iheart radio
cast box all of the places if you're
listening on youtube make sure to give
this video a thumbs up
and write a comment about maybe what
your favorite segment was anything that
made you laugh
out loud we'd love to know those sorts
of things because we love to make people
laugh out loud if you're listening as a
podcast
head to the podcast app leave a five
star review you know let us know again
what made you laugh out loud
what's what's your favorite news that we
report what segments tickle your fancy
how do you feel about man this is a long
[ __ ] wrap-up
i'm doing it my way okay yeah i did it
my
way and that is all she wrote so thank
you so much for listening
um we'll see you tomorrow society season
two what is it
um it's gonna be the
what about bells sure oh yeah bells
because of going to the chapel bells
bells bells love you guys so much we'll
see you tomorrow feel better claudia
you